what does one of the first self-driving  cars look like 1989 Back to the Future  Part 2 was released and in Pittsburgh a  retrofitted army ambulance called Alvin  was driving around Carnegie Mellon  University but the CMU graduate student  isn't driving a computer is or more  precisely a neural network Alvin stands  for autonomous land vehicle in a neural  network the car's CPU was the size of a  refrigerator and the vehicle could reach  speeds of up to 70 miles an hour unlike  Google whose car will rely on 3D maps  adaptive neural network Alvin developed  by Dean pomelo was trained to respond to  any situation on the road and it handled  it well in 1995 Alvin successfully  traveled almost 3 000 miles from  Pittsburgh to San Diego to learn more  about the use of neural networks watch  the video on the sumsub channel just  follow the link in the pinned comments